Hey everyone.
My name is Mike Tsao, and
I'm on the Chrome Apps team.
I'm here to tell
you what's happened
with the platform
since I/O 2013,
and why it makes sense for
you to write a Chrome app.
But first a refresher-- why'd we
build the Chrome Apps platform
in the first place?
The answer is simple.
We're the Chrome team.
We love the web.
HTML, CSS, and JavaScript
make a pretty awesome browser
platform.
And we wanted to use that
platform outside the browser.
For us that meant three things.
Unlocking additional
capabilities that
aren't available to
normal web pages,
making web apps as discoverable
and sticky as native apps,
and doing all this
while preserving
and even improving upon the
amazing reach of today's web.
This is what Chrome apps
offer you as a developer.
Chrome apps capabilities
fall into three groups.
Immersive UI gives you the
developer complete control
over your applications
appearance,
all the way from window
size and position
to full screen
with pointer lock.
Your apps also have low level
access to device hardware,
such as USB, Bluetooth,
and raw sockets.
And our offline by
default model ensures
that your users will
always be able to launch
your app regardless
of connectivity.
Again, through standard
web technology,
immersive UI that has powerful
hardware access and runs
offline.
That's the core of what you get
with the Chrome Apps platform.
Now building a powerful
Chrome app is easy,
but how do you get
it to your users?
We offer a distribution
flow that's
familiar to any mobile user.
The Chrome Web Store takes care
of listing, discoverability,
ratings, reviews,
purchasing, and installation.
Just upload your app and
we'll take care of the rest.
After your users have
installed your app,
the Chrome App Launcher
provides a convenient surface
for your users to return to it.
The App Launcher is
familiar to any user
of other mobile or desktop OSs.
And just in case your users
forget to launch your app,
rich notifications remind
users of important events
even if your app isn't running.
The Chrome Web Store App
Launcher and rich notifications
take care of distribution
and user retention,
letting you focus on
making a great app.
OK, you've written an immersive
and capable offline Chrome app.
You're using the Chrome
Web Store to distribute it.
The App Launcher and
rich notifications help
keep up your active
user account.
But exactly who can you
reach with your Chrome app?
This is easy.
If a device can run Chrome,
it can run your Chrome app
as well.
Chrome apps are available on
every desktop OS supported
by Chrome.
Through the Apache
Cordova project,
you can deploy your Chrome app
in iOS and Android as well.
And thanks to app_shell,
the Chrome Apps platform
will soon have a reach
even greater than Chrome.
I'll come back to
app_shell in a bit.
All right, so now you understand
what the Chrome Apps platform
is.
And if you haven't yet seen Erik
Kay's State of the Union talk
from I/O 2013, that's
still a great reference.
But I wanted to talk about
what's changed since then.
There have been quite a
few exciting developments.
First of all, shortly
after I/O 2013,
we officially
launched Chrome apps
for all supported
desktop platforms, giving
your apps the same
reach that Chrome
has on Windows, OS X,
Chrome OS, and Linux.
Next, we officially launched
mobile Chrome apps on Cordova.
Apache Cordova implements
the Chrome Apps platform
for iOS and Android.
Both these ecosystems have their
own distribution mechanisms,
and Cordova helps you
package your app accordingly.
Between Chrome and
Cordova, your Chrome app
has incredible
distribution and reach
across all major desktop
and mobile platforms.
Check out our other I/O
presentations this year
to learn more about
mobile Chrome apps.
Now, the initial September 2013
launch had some minor caveats.
I'm happy to report that we've
taken care of many of them
since then.
First and foremost, the
Chrome Apps platform
is at feature parity across all
four desktop operating systems,
including most recently App
Launcher and rich notifications
on Linux.
The Chrome team has made
architectural changes
under the hood that
will make it easier
for us to continue
rolling out new platform
features on all desktop
operating systems
simultaneously.
In addition to reaching
feature parity,
we've also improved our suite
of platform capabilities.
Managed in app payments
handles licenses
you sell for digital
goods in your Chrome app.
Free trials allow you to explore
freemium models for your app.
The new unified Google Cloud
Messaging API, or chrome.gcm,
is now in stable channel.
If you've already rolled out
an Android GCM based product,
is now much easier for you
to include the equivalent
functionality in a Chrome app.
We've added better media
scanning capabilities
to the media gallery API, which
ensures that your apps will get
appropriate access to
more user media files.
We've completely revamped many
of our hardware access APIs
to work properly with
Chrome event pages,
in the process making your
code simpler, more efficient,
and significantly faster.
The sync file system API
now has directory support,
giving your Chrome app
a fully featured sandbox
subset of the
user's Google Drive.
And finally, for those cases
where a sandbox just won't do,
Chrome apps can
communicate directly
with native applications
through native messaging.
These are just some
of the improvements
we've made to the core
platform in the last year.
Check out our
developer documentation
to get the complete set.
Of course, more platform
features are always welcome,
but a good platform needs
good developer tools as well.
While we're big fans of
the diversity of tools
and technologies available
to web developers,
it's also a good idea to
provide a well lit path that
helps beginner and
intermediate developers
fall into the pit of success.
That's why we've been working on
a couple Chrome apps of our own
specifically designed to improve
the developer experience.
First is Chrome Apps and
Extensions Developer Tool.
This is what we've always wanted
chrome:extensions to become.
If you're developing a Chrome
app or extension and have been
using chrome:extensions in
developer mode, give it a try.
The work flows much better.
Next is a project
code named Spark.
It's a code editor for
Chrome apps and web apps.
With Spark and a machine
that runs Chrome,
you have everything you need
to publish your own Chrome
app on Chrome Web Store.
The Spark team is unveiling
their developer preview at I/O,
and I encourage you to
check out their talk.
OK, great.
Now you're up to speed on
Chrome apps as of today.
So what's next?
We generally don't talk
about unannounced products,
but because Chromium is
an open source project,
I can help direct your attention
to recent source code changes
that you might find interesting.
Disclaimer-- many
of these changes
represent experiments
that might or might not
ship depending in
part of your feedback.
So please try them out and
let us know what you think.
Earlier I mentioned stickiness.
In most cases it's a good
thing to encourage your users
to return to your app
after initial launch.
But what if your app really
isn't meant to be sticky?
What if your app is
associated with a calendar
event or a sight
seeing location?
What if your app
is so lightweight
that the installation
step is a burden?
Ephemeral Chrome apps
have a simpler life cycle
that optimizes the
installation and removal steps.
The vision is simple.
Make installation optional,
replacing the Add button
with Launch.
Several versions of this
experiment are available now
on chrome:flags.
Back to the core
of the platform,
we're expanding and
improving hardware support
and improving existing
functionality based on feedback
from app developers.
If you've tried out the
Chrome Apps USB API,
there's a good chance
you've run into a roadblock
that it can't see devices
describing themselves
in whole or in
part as HID class.
To clear this roadblock,
we have a new USB HID
API in dev channel now
for Windows and OS X.
And we're working on Linux
and Chrome OS support now.
Many newer Bluetooth devices
are BLE, or Bluetooth Low Energy
devices.
BLE is part of Bluetooth 4.
It calls for a new API.
And we're building that API
so your apps can connect
to fitness bands, wrist watches,
home sensors, medical monitors,
and other smart devices.
Check out
chrome.bluetoothlowenergyapi
for more.
Next, manifest v3.
Bumping a Chrome
app Manifest Version
is a chance to bring
forward best practices
and deprecate discouraged ones.
It's also a chance to
introduce cool new platform
features, such as a promises
based version of our platform
APIs.
We're getting ready to define
what v3 is going to look like,
and we look forward to
hearing from you about it.
Earlier I mentioned a
project called app_shell.
app_shell is a
Chromium build target
that offers a stripped down
version of the Chrome app's
runtime suitable for
two major use cases.
First, kiosk style
applications where
you know the only thing
the kiosk is going to do
is run your app, and
there's no reason
why you'd need a
full web browser.
Second, limited
resource environments
running on bare bones
embedded hardware.
The app_shell team is
already demonstrating
that a Chrome app can run on
a small fraction of the memory
and storage of the
full Chrome browser,
and they're investigating ways
to shrink it even further.
We'd like Chrome apps to go
places that Chrome can't, and
app_shell is leading the way.
Now, as I said before,
we're the Chrome team
and we love the web.
And the Chrome Apps team
is excited about sharing
parts of what we've
developed with the web.
Elsewhere at I/O, you'll hear
Alex Russell and Jake Archibald
telling you about an
upcoming contender
for web standard
called service worker.
Service worker is at its heart
an event page for the open web.
If you're already a
Chrome app developer,
then you'll
recognize Chrome apps
event pages and Service
Worker's lineage.
Event pages provide a
richer app lifetime model.
And we're excited to see
wider adoption of that model.
We're also using our
Chrome apps experience
to research different ways
to present open web content.
The streamlined
hosted apps experiment
let's end users treat regular
websites like Chrome apps,
with top level windows and
a spot in the App Launcher.
For a lot of sites,
this presentation mode
makes a lot of sense.
Give it a try in chrome:flags.
OK, now you're caught up with
today's Chrome apps platform.
Using standard safe
web technology,
you get immersive UI, hardware
access, great offline behavior,
easy distribution and retention,
and a familiar native app
experience across
desktop and mobile.
We built the Chrome
Apps platform
because we believed it
would be a better way
to safely deliver application
functionality to users.
Every day, more
and more people are
convinced, and every
day more and more
people are buying Chromebooks
as second and sometimes
first computers.
If you want to reach the users
who are buying into the Chrome
app sandbox model, then you
need to build a Chrome app.
We think we're
onto something big,
and we'd like you
to be a part of it.
Now is a great time to capture
the attention of millions
of Chromebook users
with your Chrome app.
So go build it.
To get started, visit
the Chrome app site here.
Thanks for watching.